let's talk about what's happening with
the war in Libya they've been fighting
over the capital Tripoli since last
April and now world leaders in Berlin
have promised to observe an existing
arms embargo that was being ignored but
the permanent ceasefire deal they'd
hoped for went nowhere after Berlin
people will be watching with this
renegade general does next
but who is Khalifa Haftar and what is
the battle for Tripoli all about the
fighting in Libya has been on and off
ever since the Arab Spring uprising in
2011 part of the problem was the killing
of Muammar Gaddafi that year Libya is a
country full of different tribes and
Gaddafi strategy towards governing Libya
for 40 years was the play those tribes
up against one another once Gaddafi was
out of the picture the place became
lawless tribes and militias that had
fought together to overthrow Gaddafi
turned against each other to fill the
power vacuum created by his death
fighting hasn't really stopped since and
if it did it didn't for long and right
now there's a battle for Libya's capital
the man who wants to take over is
Khalifa Haftar in the late 1960s half
dar was Gaddafi's friend and helped put
him in power he became one of Libya's
top military leaders but in the late 80s
one of HOF DARS missions in Chad went
wrong and long story short he fell out
with Gaddafi and ended up living in the
US for 20 years he even became an
American citizen after only came back to
Libya once the Arab Spring hit he
eventually set himself up in the east
and started consolidating power with
help from Egypt and the United Arab
Emirates he built what he called the
Libyan National Army it's estimated the
LNA has at least 25,000 fighters - half
of our career as we know him today
really began in July 2013 and his
promise was quite simple what [ __ ] was
for Egypt he was going to try and be in
Libya he realized that there was a need
for a classical conventional Arab Sunni
military he figured with of course it
goes without saying another chronic
slant to it all one thing that's
important in understanding Libya is that
it has two rival administrations pop
darkness forces back one of them the
House of Representatives based in the
east in the city of Tobruk the other is
known as the government of national
court GNA works out of Tripoli and is
recognized by the UN it relies on what's
left of Libya's formal military as well
as militias to keep control
but some of half-dollars allies like
Egypt and the UAE have a problem with
the GNA mainly it's links to political
Islam including the Muslim Brotherhood
because those ideological parents are
seen as a threat to the regime's that
decided to support NAFTA in 2014 the
problem that after has with any
government whether it's above him or
opposed to him or one that has been
appointed by him is that he doesn't want
to share power here's something else
about half dar he's unpredictable
a year ago it looked like peace talks
were going somewhere and the UN and
other world powers thought Hoffner was
on board but in April 2019 just days
before a UN peace conference on Libya
huffner surprised everyone with an
assault in Tripoli half those forces
have been trying to seize the capital
Tripoli from the UN backed government
since then huffner has been fighting
militias loyal to the GNA and now he's
got new help for mercenaries some of
them from Russia the battle has
displaced thousands of people and more
than 200 civilians have been killed
he promised at the time that he was
going to be able to in three days enter
tripling eradicate corruption dismantle
all the munitions called the DNA so it
was a crazy adventure in the sense that
it was remarkably ambitious right now
world powers are trying to get the rival
sides to agree to a ceasefire but there
are more countries involved in Libya
than ever on the GNA side you've got the
UN Italy Qatar and Turkey whose
Parliament recently approved sending
ground forces to Tripoli lieutenant
Masaru unit imminent Bolivia toxic our
destiny mrs. Sal de la serda Messiah
Linda Darby after a rocket did their
severe matenda hasta gay leader meters
but Huff tower has important friends too
like Egypt France Russia Saudi Arabia
and the UAE a lot of states have
supported him mainly the United Arab
Emirates who have run a full-blown fleet
of combat drones Olivia with Devi
air strikes which have turned out to be
very destructive but not very effective
and what are some of the things that
world powers want while countries like
Turkey want the GNA to survive because
among other things it wants drilling
rights for oil and gas in the
Mediterranean Libya also has a lot of
oil and countries like Italy have oil
companies in there they want to protect
others say they're serious about
stabilizing a country that's not had
peace and far too long and if you're
wondering how bad it could get Germany
says Libya could become a second Syrian
[Music]
we've only just scratched the surface
with what's going on in Libya and there
are lots of moving parts but we are
following this story very closely across
al Jazeera so like and subscribe to all
our social media pages to keep up with
the latest I'll see you next week
[Music]